y estos camiones están cargados de
alimentos y mantas en este distrito que
se salvó del terremoto la población se
está movilizando todos los días se
envían ayuda a los más afectados en las
aldeas remotas situadas a 50 km las
necesidades son muy grandes la comunidad
internacional tiene que ayudarnos porque
afganistán está atravesando una crisis y
todas las personas afectadas son muy
pobres y están en zonas remotas
los camiones de las organizaciones
locales e internacionales tienen que
circular por estas pistas de montaña
duras y llenas de baches
los motores de nuestros camiones están
sobrecalentados la carretera está en muy
mal estado estamos llevando ayuda a las
víctimas llevamos bolsas de harina y
aceite
pero la ayuda todavía no llega a los
pueblos más afectados como este todas
las casas han quedado parcialmente
destruidas aquí de casos dos personas
murieron aquí el techo se derrumbó sobre
ellos eran niños pequeños y suites y
sofá
todos dormían cuando la tierra tembló
fuertemente el martes por la noche
ninguna de las habitaciones resistió el
violento temblor
cuando el techo se derrumbó
afortunadamente pude retener una parte
para que mi mujer pudiera salir pero
perdí a mis dos hijos no me queda nada
lo he perdido todo
era mi hija
los supervivientes de esta extensa
familia viven ahora en el patio en esta
esfera de plástico
aquí es donde pasan los días y las
noches cuando la casa se derrumbó todas
nuestras pertenencias quedaron
enterradas bajo los escombros ni
siquiera tenemos mantas sólo tenemos dos
pequeñas porciones de arroz y algo de
pan perdimos a los dos hijos de mi
hermano a mi hermana ya sus cuatro hijos
a tres primos ya dos primas hemos
perdido a doce miembros de la familia en
total estamos muy tristes no tenemos
corazón para comer en lo más profundo
del distrito es donde más daños hay esta
casa de adobe es inhabitable estas cajas
son todo lo que se pudo rescatar de los
escombros
gharib en aguas está destrozado
esta habitación está dañada
afortunadamente no hubo muertos ni
heridos pero todo aquí las mantas las
alfombras son inservibles esta casa era
perfecta la construimos hace solo dos
años ahora tenemos que derrumbar la y
reconstruirla
la ayuda tarda en llegar a los pueblos
de difícil acceso la distribución en las
zonas afectadas es ahora el mayor reto